gervais vespière merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation des lectures et rt
france alors le directeur international
de l' agence internationale de l'énergie
atomique rappelle marianne aux
grossistes se rendra donc demain en iran
quels sont les enjeux de cette visite à
quoi peut-on s'attendre
les enjeux sont double premièrement il y
a les écarts que l'iran a commis en
sortant donc des paramètres techniques
enrichissement nombre de centrifugeuses
a donc la russie à la chine demande à
l'iran de rester dans l'accord et les
trois puissances européennes demandent à
l'iran de revenir à un accord donc là ce
sont les caractéristiques techniques de
l'accord et vient se greffer depuis le
mois de mars
la confirmation par là la direction de
l'agencé internationale à l'énergie
atomique qu'il y avait effectivement sur
un site qui n'était pas inspecté à des
traces d'uranium avec modification
humaine ce n'est pas de l'uranium de
basse et eu de l'uranium qui avait été
transformée par des procédés
physico-chimiques donc jusqu'à présent
l'iran a nié et refuse d inspection soit
installations là donc il ya ce sujet
plus les paramètres autour de l'accord
alors on leur à plérin donald trump a
demandé le rétablissement de l'ensemble
des sanctions internationales contre
l'iran ce que refusent les pays
signature de l'accord de vienne est ce
que les américains peuvent obtenir gain
de cause aujourd'hui à ça va être
difficile je pense qu'il ya un moyen
terme à obtenir de la part de téhéran a
il faut que téhéran fasse quelque chose
puisque il y à des écarts entre le
les termes de l'accord ce que je vienne
exprimé sur le ring l'uranium qu'il se
trouvait sur un site qui n'aurait pas dû
s'y trouver
donc il faut que effectivement le
pouvoir à téhéran face à un mouvement
pour que éventuellement les etats unis
puissent de leur côté en ferrain on
l'entendait dans le sujet diffusé
précédemment le ton est monté cette
semaine dans le dossier du nucléaire
iranien le chef de la diplomatie
américaine my pompéo a accusé la france
le royaume uni et l'allemagne d'avoir
choisi de s'aligner sur les ayatollahs
quelle est la position exacte de ces
pays royaume uni l'allemagne et la
france dans ce dossier a donc les trois
pays que vous venez de citer
demande instamment à téhéran de revenir
dans l'accord donc de réduire à nouveau
le nombre de centrifugeuses d'euros
diminuer le pourcentage d'enrichissement
d'abaisser à nouveau le stock de lourdes
le stock d'uranium enrichi donc il y a
ces paramètres là que berlin à londres
et paris à souhaite voir respectés pour
que effectivement il puisse y avoir un
levier vis-à-vis de washington tant que
à l'iran ne modifiera aucun des
paramètres mais les iraniens ne sont pas
sortis énormément de l'accord ce sont 7
a été une politique de petits pas très
bien calculé de quelques pourcents de
changement par rapport aux termes de
l'accord
donc il faudrait que sur un ou deux ou
trois paramètres les iraniens soir avec
un implant étalé dans le temps
accepte de revenir d'ailleurs les
iraniens ont repris l'enrichissement de
leur uranium est ce qu'un stade se
trouvent aujourd'hui leur programme
nucléaire on sait il est vraiment pas
très loin des termes de l'accord il y a
eu de la part de téhéran une politique
des petits pas justement pour pas risqué
pour éviter que les trois pays européens
se retrouvent dans le camp de washington
si je puis dire donc de façon à garder
cette différence entre l'europe et les
états unis
les iraniens sont restés
quelques encablures seulement des termes
de l'accord donc l'écart n'est pas un
n'est pas énorme à ils ont augmenté
l'enrichissement de 1% seulement au
revoir à les d'uranium également donc il
n'y a pas grande écart technique a
modifié de leur côté pour revenir pour
conclure l'accord de vienne peut-il
survivre en retrait des états unis les
états unis de parler les termes de
signatures sont toujours dans l'accord
ils se sont éloignés des terres mais il
reste signataires donc il y à un hiatus
juridique si vous voulez entre les
décisions qui ont été prises par
washington et la signature qui a été
faite par obama en 2015 donc pour le
moment ils sont toujours l'intérieur a
c'est une grande partie de poker
international et donc effectivement
chacun cherche les limites de l'autre
merci beaucoup gérard vestiaires d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes chercheur associé à la
fondation d'études pour le moyen-orient